[Applause]
the man behind everything iconic mr
iconic himself and pop culture nostalgic
guru with a podcast of over 22 million
streams it's danny pellegrini i
am blushing i what an intro i'm so happy
to be here i'm so excited thank you for
having me all right well what are we
talking about today okay so we're
talking about nostalgia candy my
favorite of all times i love nerds do
you remember nerds you guys do people
still eat them my daughters love nerds
yeah i got ice cream if i had one nerd
i'd have to take a nap now i haven't had
sugar in forever i love a sour patch i
would jump in front of a bus for a
payday
which i pay i consider a payday a
protein bar because on the package it's
peanutty right
it's peanuts and caramel and in a
package it says seven grams of protein
with a big exclamation point so i
believe that's them telling us it's
healthy i agree i
love skittles because my daughters love
skittles and
um they're just like such a refreshing
you know chocolate sometimes you're like
i need water it feels kind of like muddy
in your mouth which there's nothing
wrong with that but skittles are like
they're just so delightful and
refreshing danny um
you actually uh i just get all
yeah
taste the rainbow taste the ramen
can i have one yes yes so we gotta talk
about these uh warhead drinks no i
mentioned warhead this is a warhead
seltzer hard seltzer now i've never
tried it before it could be terrible and
these are that crazy sour candy now it's
a drink i guess so okay i'm gonna try
one i'm gonna try the candy because i've
never tried one
this is the color of windex i just want
to say it out loud
okay
oh my god
oh my god it's very wet
oh my god
oh you're trying the candy's really sour
wait did you not know what this time
have you never had one before
true i wanted us to all try the warhead
and try to do a monologue from one of
your classic movies i've never been
kissed ross you're going to go first so
this is the epic prom night speech
pop it in your mouth and you got it
okay that is sour
okay this is the line oh wow
hold on all right
let me tell you something
i don't care about
being your stupid prom queen i'm 25
years old
why are you doing this to me
i'm an underground reporter for the
chicago times
and i've been
beating my brains out trying to pressure
people this is torture okay now i'm
gonna i'm gonna try to take the lead
here
let me tell you something gibby kirsten
and kristen
you will spend your life trying to
figure out
how to keep others down because it makes
you feel more important why her
true
you have to put a fresh one in
[Music]
[Laughter]
there's a big world out there
bigger than prom because
it won't matter if you were
the bomb queen or the quarterback of the
football team
or the biggest nerd in school
i know who you are
i try not to be afraid of it yeah
oh my god give her the oscar
i'm not kidding it like i i have like
like a brain freeze but like a sour
freeze yes
red rash
thank you ross thank you danny
get more from danny on the everything i
caught
and beware of the warheads we'll be
right back
[Applause]
[Music]
you